like oh I have Wendy Williams or feet
I'm friends with Wendy Williams I just
think you know again it's it's an it's
an attempt to be more relevant than
anyone else on the show and it's just
like a failed attempt to me what's one
word to describe the rest of the season
of Atlanta oh I don't know if you can
describe it in one word maybe a phrase
rollercoaster ride a rollercoaster ride
okay yeah on the room that tracks no pun
intended
yeah let's dig into some stuff that's
coming up on the show because we got
that midseason tease yes a lot of stuff
going down with your favorite person
linnethia uh yes from the looks of the
tease it seems as if she tried to go
around make amends maybe bury some
hatchets can you agree why didn't that
work because it's not genuine I think
that you know I was in our last season
but last season she certainly was not
friends with anyone she was a man on an
island and in order to integrate herself
back into the cast she had to make
amends with people so that's not genuine
you're just making up with people
because you have to because you have no
one else that wants to film with you or
nothing else to do you know so that's
what that is you and Nene left on pretty
good terms at the end of your season
when you walked away so no one
understood what is this all about yeah
so do you understand what it's all about
I understand what it was about because
I've been in this really loved hateful
relationship with her and all the hate
is coming from her you know it's so much
and you know she tried to get me fired
before I was even hired on the show I
just think that she's always been very
intimidated by my presence on the show
and when I was not on the show I was
still being talked about maybe those
scenes didn't make it on the show but I
was still me you also talked about I was
still relevant so that bothered her and
so then it
why did you invite Kenya to your you
know your launch party to celebrate you
and as eight eight months pregnant like
why is that an issue for you yeah
so again if you watch who she really is
you will see that she is extremely
intimidated jealous envious whatever you
want to call it of my presence on the
show let's talk about Kenya was she the
reason that you hesitated coming back I
wouldn't give her that much credit
really absolutely how do you feel about
her now I don't have a feeling what do
you mean just what I see have you been
able to unpack that at all with her or
is it kind of like that's where it lives
I know what it is she wants to that's
why she tried so hard to tell people
she's the HBIC she's this she's the
originator oh the real premier just
starts and in fact her presence now is
not impactful at all she's missed out on
at least four to five episodes this
season so that clearly means that the
network is sending you a message
you're not as important as you think you
are the message is very clear either the
network feels that you're still a
valuable asset on the show or they don't
and you're replaced or phased out and
you just have to move on
meaning it's been on this show for a
very long time and I just think the cast
is not gelling with her she always puts
herself on an island she makes these
fights with people that don't actually
have to occur and she's really the cause
of her own demise and so I looked at my
phone in between commercials and Nene
texts I'm quitting what do you make of
Wendy Williams exposing that she texted
her and said I want to quit as long as
she still has tons of bills to pay Meany
will not walk away from a check and I
just think she's using Wendy honestly
because before Wendy would go in if she
sees the type of behavior that anyone on
our show was exhibiting before and when
he has been like going so soft on her so
I just think that Mimi is really just
using Wendy what was interesting is
beginning that midseason teaser Wendy's
gonna make an appearance via
phone call somebody pushes me maybe I'm
going to say sis like why like I again
Nene reaching for something to make her
feel like she's more important than
everyone else like oh I have Wendy
Williams or feed on I'm friends with
Wendy Williams and I just think you know
again it's it's an it's an attempt to be
more relevant than anyone else on the
show and it's just like a failed attempt
to me do you gonna do not with me man me
what you want go to jail there's what
looks like maybe a few big blow ups
coming including the long teased did she
or did she not spit yes spit Gators are
we officially labeling it's pinky I
think it's safe to label it as spit gate
how do we get to that point how do we
get to that point that is my question
you're 50 something years old and we're
on a television show and you get to the
point where you're spitting you know
food at someone she's fat food at me she
attempted to actually hawk up spit to
spit on me
and it's just like what holds us back
you have children you have grandchildren
you are grandmother and this is the
example that you're setting this came
out because you you brought that up in
the way you're Wendy interview before we
had seen that footage yeah Nene
immediately did I die and though she use
the word I was actually lying
she said lying and then we get this
footage and it proves I said exactly
what I said it was the truth you can't
lie if it's on video do you have any
hopes for your relationship with Nene I
won't even call it a friendship because
I feel like that surpassed that point
yeah yeah we don't have a friendship I
don't think we ever did have a
friendship I think I was just convenient
and a convenient ally and so yeah I
don't really see the value in being or
attempting to be fake friends with her
but you don't think she will of her own
volition walk away from this group never
not if there's a chick involved
if she is phased out to borrow your
phrase well she's already been cut out
quite a few episodes
is there anybody kind of in the mix
right now that you would love to see her
place her fans want to see Marlo at the
penis Marla will never get a peach in my
opinion you know listen she has a
horrible criminal past that's just not
Bravo's brand and if she's been on the
show for all of these years doing the
same thing why do you would you want to
make her a housewife
I mean you've gotten her as the friend
of the show for 10 years why make our
house life now it just to me it's just
not good business but I can't understand
it but listen it's not - another network
exec I'm not the network I think that
out of the people in the mix I do think
that Tanya deserves a peach I think that
she's interesting she's a little quirky
and I think that she has a dark side
okay yeah I do
the fact is you are real I would like
that just to get more of your tan your
impression on the show you give me a
little tenure right oh my god like I'm
on this set this is so cool like really
it's so bright and it's like still Aryan
there's like a wonderful oh my god it's
kind of like Atlanta's Disney Princess
yeah oh my god I'm like so innocent but
I'm really not I just pretend to be oh
yeah can we get into wig gate listen I
might have something on her what does
that mean is Tanya I mean this is me be
[Music]
yeah I mean how'd it really disappoint
in it what did you make of her thinking
that was tianyu like that that was
something to expect so this is how I
look at things what was your intent so
your intent was to embarrass me to
discredit me because everyone knows I
have a very successful haircare line
promoting your natural hair growing your
natural hair which by the way it's all
my hair so for her to bring a wig
clearly it wasn't on my head but also
I'm on TV so if I need to wear a wig one
day if I'm filming or something because
my hair is a mess and I have no
hairdressers around because we were in
Toronto then that's what it is but I
don't wear them every day I think she
knew exactly what she was doing because
she found out that I was at some point
speaking about Paul her fiance of eight
years and their relationship and so that
was her passive-aggressive way to try to
hurt me to try to discredit me and try
to make me look that if she lied and
said I lied about the wig I'm like no I
never lied about I just didn't answer
Marlowe right because you weren't going
to feed the beast
exactly it have a whole moment with
Marlowe thank you
it cracked me up the way in Kandi's
confessional she's like you do not come
at Kenya unless you have like savage
move did you endorse that when you are
like yes can all right you've had spit
Gate wig gate now it's getting a snake
game yes five times okay so no okay
so we're moving on have you heard
anything maybe even sad you said you
never even hear me tell me who reported
me are we ever gonna get this alleged
audio does this audio even exist I have
said all along maybe the first two
meetings I had with the girls and I
listen I listen on a different level
than everyone else
I really do and I can decipher the truth
fact and fiction very quickly
maybe the second time I heard about it I
said there's no audio this is a lie Nene
made it all up this is a lie there's no
audio but you know now we're seeing is
there audio or not and you'll get to
that in the next few episodes okay so we
will get an answer on that front I
believe you will get an answer yes
have we seen the last of Jovana oh I
don't yeah I hope so I don't think we've
seen someone so thirsty to be a part of
this group ever before on this show I
mean it's just like it's just grossly
thirsty thirsty I mean everyone is
thirsty to a degree I mean it's a great
platform right you know it's launched a
lot of careers it's keeping women of
color employed over the age of 40 you
know some checks are you know
seven-figure checks possibly so it's
just like okay this is a great platform
to be so yeah I don't mind someone being
thirsty
I just mind them being like thirsty all
right reunion is coming up yes it's been
a minute since you had to go to our
reunion yes it has yes it has how are
you I still have it yeah how are you
feeling about it I still read a [ __ ] I
don't have any question I think that was
you know listen I think reunion is going
to be a little tough for me because I
definitely have had problems with
several of the ladies this season from
Eva early on - you know Marlo - Tanya -
Nene and Cynthia so it's gonna be a
tough reunion for me well than all the
personal life stuff we're about to see a
mile in my own personal life yes are you
it's just a very it's gonna be a very
tough reunion for me
are you prepared before then to watch
all that back and see that journey
unfold on to you know and also you know
we don't get the episodes into like two
or three days before they aired so you
just never know what the cut is what the
edit is how you're going to look what
was actually said what was included what
wasn't so it's hard it's really hard it
sounds like you're bracing for a lot of
people to come at you but what's the
number one thing you want to get
clarified or the question you want
answered there why do they never give me
a pass
you know they give it to everyone else
but they never give me a pass and they
always look to make me look bad or make
me look like a villain and my heart is
always in the right place it might be
misguided sometimes or might get caught
up in a situation like you know look the
proposal but come on I bet it's my
friend you know and even though I might
be going through tough times in my own
life it has nothing to do with my
friendships yeah I would want to know
that okay that might be a question for
Andy then there you have it it's last
reunion Nene showed up but I don't think
Nene was actually there the fact that
you would sit here now and give a big
you to all of us is very hurtful now I
cannot leave this damn couch without
saying it what's your response no
response no response do you think she
will actually show up to this reunion I
think she possibly will because she's
fighting to stay on the show so she
might bring a little bit more this time
okay at the end of the day all said and
done are you happy with your decision to
come back to housewives yeah and you
know I I have gone through some hard
times but I've been through worse on the
show and I survived and I'm stronger for
it and at the end of the day this is my
legacy for my daughter and I just want
her to be able to be proud of her mom
I'm a CEO mom I have a very successful
you know Kenya Moore hair care company
and one day she might have to take over
that business and and so I want her to
see my mom was a real boss
[Music]